we are received with a real
grandmother's welcome
tomorrow victor even has been living
here since 1958.
but i'm russian i was born in russia and
i love ukraine
i have a sister in russia and i asked my
sister will your son come to fight my
son
ukrainians and russians share history
many family ties cross the front lines
she shows us her father's death
certificate a russian soldier he fought
and died during the second world war now
it's the russians that have made tamra's
grandson's wife and child leave for
poland
she helped drive them to levive and he
has stayed on to fight
and at 88 years old she has returned to
odessa
the trip to the beef was really terrible
it reminded me of when i ever created
during the second world war
i had my parents protection my
grandmother and mother but this time i
was the protector and it's terrible
when we came to life i saw a lot of
people by the railway station
it
it was the russians who fought to
protect odessa during the second world
war fortifying the city
just as is being done now
but 80 years on yesterday's protector
has turned today's enemy
dimitro never imagined war would come
not on this scale
he now uses his kitchen to cook for
soldiers and refugees
he worked in moscow for five years most
of his friends there don't believe what
is happening here
you can't imagine the level of
propaganda in moscow most of my friends
really believe their media
when i try to explain the reality they
told me that i was wrong and that we are
under ukrainian propaganda
but this war
is very real
every day it gets more dangerous
especially as we are getting used to the
air raid sirens we are no longer
reacting no longer going to shelters and
this is dangerous
the russians haven't stopped their
effort to take odessa
but tamara does take heed of the air
raid sirens i ask her what she does when
she hears them
she has an emergency bag ready to go
medicine underwear phone charger
documents it's all she takes she tells
us this bag and her cat
are you are you scared
yet
absolutely
they can't break us even if they
surround us we will still push them back
we will never give zamadesam because we
love adessa we call her mama odessa
she says gardening calms her mind
spring is here she tells us
the flowers will come
confident for better days
stephanie decker al-jazeera odessa in
southwestern ukraine